à peine 10 heures du matin et le mercure
atteint déjà les 33 degrés sur richmond
capitale de la virginie partout dans la
ville les citoyens ont chaud mais
certains plus que d'autres et me once
nous fait visiter le south side de
richmond un secteur défavorisé ou deux
miss et les maisons mobiles côtoient
industrie commerce défraîchi et hôtels
de passe
fenêtres des maisons rideau de fortune
tente bloquer les rayons du soleil à
l'extérieur
pas d'ombré en vue que d'habitude il n'y
a pas d'arbres ici dit elle imaginez
attendre l'autobus sous cette chaleur le
long de cet horrible boulevard sans
nulle part où s'abriter où s'asseoir le
directeur scientifique du musée des
sciences de la virginie jérémie hoffmann
traque depuis des années les écarts de
température d'un quartier à l'autre
d'une ville à l'autre
et les résultats sont parfois
spectaculaires jusqu'à 9 degrés celsius
de différence à l'intérieur de la ville
de richmond
le même jour à la même heure des
inégalités dont les racines remontent à
près d'un siècle dans une étude
pionnière publié l'an dernier il a
établi un lien entre les écarts de
températures enregistrées aujourd'hui et
le raid linings cette pratique
discriminatoire des années 30 consistait
à priver de prêts hypothécaires garantis
des secteurs essentiellement à majorité
noire ou investir étaient considérés
plus risqués pour d'argent ces quartiers
marquée au fer rouge ont peu à peu
périclité apprend d'être ciblés pour
l'aménagement d'autoroutes et la
construction du sinn
bref plus d'asphalté de béton moins
d'arbres et des espaces verts et les
conséquences se font encore sentir
aujourd'hui car sans surprise les
quartiers les plus exposés à la chaleur
sont aussi ceux qui en subissent les
conséquences les plus funestes appel au
9-1-1 plus fréquents maladies
pulmonaires exacerbée décès
les choses sont pourtant en train de
changer
brian greene du département d'état de
richmond fait visiter à des résidents du
south side ce qui espère qu'il deviendra
leur nouvelle oasis 30 hectares de boisé
jusqu'ici laissées à l'abandon qui
seront aménagés en parc ces prochains
mois un de cinq projets prévus il faut
regarder notre histoire en face dit-il
sans quoi nous répéterons les mêmes
erreurs il s'est donné pour objectif que
chacun de ses citoyens se trouve à 10
minutes ou moins à pied d'un parc ou
d'un espace vert un privilège auquel
n'ont pas droit trois résidents sur dix
à l'heure actuelle surtout dans les
quartiers défavorisés
le point de départ de cet ambitieux
projet les travaux de génie hoffman en
bonne partie in space à l'abri sous les
arbres et me once termine sa visite
guidée en nous faisant découvrir le west
end de richmond
la végétation est luxuriante l'air frais
le soleil dissimulé derrière d'épaisses
couches de feuillages fr
ce n'est vraiment pas juste ce n'est pas
que les gens ici ne devrait pas avoir
tout ça c'est que nous aussi nous le
méritons